I already know man bootleg can calm my
94 one-way the back of the bus
my brother schoolboy q you already know
so schoolboy last time we talked man
everybody you were like very hesitant to
give away a lot of having details not
yet number one album in the country man
how you feeling now my voice is [__]
up still smoking weed I'm just torn
right now I'm gonna just tour for the
rest of the year
yeah you got a busy a 51-day tour right
now yeah yeah I got well it was actually
started off for 70 something but I did a
few shows to a night
oh [__] I'm saying cuz we saw them all
too fast so we have to do too but yeah
I'm just torn right now I wasn't gonna
start on now the next I'm June
but push that back a little bit yeah
push it back cuz I'm cute somewhere um
where were you at when you first got the
news that you were the oxymoron hit
number one cause on tour you're on the
bus New York you were in New York I had
to show them New York damn my phone was
blowing up I see the first scripts this
loop to have another one
you has made first West Coast versus
game
just going crazy that's true because
even cos catch it was up - yeah man
that's some wild [__]
that's one that's a little [__] um last
time I interviewed you man was in AZ and
and you had told me I'd actually what
the theme that I was gonna be and you
pretty much said it was feeding your
daughter and your daughter makes
appearances throughout the whole album
why was it so important for you to
include her throughout the whole woman
to to articulate that point um she she
inspired it you know just the stories of
taking me back to what I was doing what
I was doing when I was like dental
depression and she didn't take care of
her nice I was still
to take care of her but I really wasn't
still taking care of it it was like just
in my mind what I wanted to do you know
and then she inspired me to write this
record because you know I wanted to put
my bass in his album but I wanted to put
the past on this album like up the time
where I was doing bad trying to take
care of my daughter at that time frame
so this was like my 20 in 19 no 20 and
21 year old like life
21 22 like their life like that's a
teacher wise man put sugar free on the
out which I thought was crazy cuffs on
the house to like you know og westco's
hands man like sugar free in particular
how did you come to get sugar free on
Rach come on man
yeah I'm a big fan of sugar free you
know saying like big fan like after POC
die like shaking free like cuz like the
man yeah yeah very underrated yeah you
know and I grew up where I grew up it
was like the ganga temps and like
prostitution I figured you know yeah but
my hat but I was never a pimp you know
and I mean like I never was a pimp I
never owned a prostitute about like that
but I've seen every day welcome to the
story you know I mean I see prostitutes
all can I be banished
little cars here seen pimps like my name
schoolboy comes from the pen don't [__]
on to me it comes from me having good
grades in school but the original school
board for my yeah
so many sexy pushing for free on my
story that I seen yeah I mean what I got
was it the type of like studio situation
where he came in and was an mp3 joint
but I was last minute I had to turn my
album in with like a week and I just
need it I did that song oh my god he
should be free that's great Oh hit me up
I hit him you Araki hooked up again on
this joint
bonus bonus doing how do you do the lux
Edition for that one yeah by the way
thank you for making the deluxe edition
like a real deluxe edition there's a lot
of people that put two songs on it but
uh you want you and rocky everyone talks
about you guys doing a full fledged
project together but is who's somebody
besides like obvious candidates who
somebody that if you could lock yourself
in the studio with for a week and put
out you know put something out together
with somebody to somebody else that you
know comes to mind anybody whether it be
someone from the past or whatever
nobody
yeah just if I was to do a project with
somebody I just be rocking me Iraqi you
know me because we came up together
oh yeah say the same time you know
we got that [__]
I know that you had talked in the past
about you know dealing with the lien
[__] and and staying off of it and then
you know you you do it a little bit
recreationally last time we talked that
on the joint prescription you talk about
the popping pills which is what a lot of
I think it's like the new the new drug
everybody's doing this [__] it's the
most accessible drug you just [__]
open there at the medicine cabinet you
don't I'm saying but uh how how are you
doing how are you doing with the lien
[__] right now you don't see it I don't
see no copy here I see is weeds that's
dope Congrats on that is beautiful thank
you
I keep also hearing that like there's
actually really moves being made to make
a black hippy album is that is that
something that's been officially being
talked about right now
he's a sheep man you know what I'm
saying I don't know I mean hopefully one
day we link up but I'm on tour right now
we gotta get Sam Souls out we gotta get
j-roc album out we gotta get kids
reading the second how about so until
those albums out you don't expect to run
of that kid
and you worry about you already got the
second album in mind oh yeah for sure
I'm already ready to go
but my creative juices flowing again it
just came back to me like three days ago
that's dope you know what I'm saying
like cuz you know you be in the studio
for so long
cuz I've been done with this album since
like January right I've been doing no
music get on I mean and it took all the
way up to now to get back into the flow
of wanna get back in the studio and new
ideas and just getting creative again
when you when you get that feeling like
the juices are rolling like you say you
start writing do you I mean you got like
a stash of beats it may be you know you
didn't know I called up my go-to guys
yeah
Carla Desiree or call it a bezoar Carlo
you know like my dudes are you know I'm
saying
then I work but all the time I hit them
up 7% something then we go from there
then I hear something I like about to
bring them into the studio come on down
the only meaning let's change this up
I'm sure and someone who was on the
don't like sound cover everyone's
talking about this new freshmen cover
besides TDE candidates so Isaiah Rashad
would be disqualified who was one or two
maybe three guys you think should be on
that cover who you'd like to see on it
this next go-round
so maybe people
rich on the quad
yeah I think they probably got you in
case he needs to get down like finantial
ty dolla sign
yes those are I think I think I think
they all got a good chance to chance to
Robert if he wants to do it's already on
the source cover by
if he wants to do it yeah
how do you cancel Vic yes
I think you named it man
yeah
number of files you go on South by man I
know you ran into a lot of people who
was someone who kind of big drew up on
that you were like [__] yeah Kanye I
make yeah you know what I saw that how'd
that conversation with Kanye West oh
[__] I was just smoking weed but you
know me in order to do is that like the
other cameras are like trying to get
pictures with everybody I know just
chillin smoking weed and he just comes
out of the crowd and sees me walks over
I was telling me that he was just
bumping just half my
that's like all the way yeah sure sure
you know then he invited me to the show
and did you guys exchange info the Kanye
TV official on record situation I know I
know kind of Kendrick toured with him
but you know yeah I mean he invited me
to the show you want me to throw me in
the crowd emotion I appreciate you as
always my brother you already know go
get that oxymoron go see more internet
we in this trippy as blue light right
now Ruby Q for real smokes